في هذه الأثناء في غزة ما
زال ما يصل إلى 600 أمريكي محاصرين في غزة
لم يتم إجلاؤهم لم
يسمح لهم بالخروج إلى مصر
يواجهون قصفًا من الإسرائيليين
أزمة إنسانية متفاقمة أه في وقت سابق من
هذا الأسبوع تحدثت مع أبو عقال وهو
من  ماساتشوستس استمع إلى ما
قاله لشبكة CNN قبل يومين فقط،
كل ما يتطلبه الأمر هو صاروخ واحد وضربة جوية واحدة
لتخطئ هدفها أو أن تكون
قريبًا جدًا من المكان الذي تتواجد فيه، نحاول أن
نبقى أقوياء، لكن لا يسعنا إلا أن
نشعر  ميؤوس منها ومهجورة أه نظرًا لقد
مضى 18 يومًا وأه حتى الآن لا توجد
مساعدة ملموسة من أه
وزارة الخارجية أعلم أنه لا يمكنك فقط إرسال
فريق الختم السادس للحصول على الرهائن في
أنفاق حماس لأنك أولاً
لا تعرف حتى  أين هم ولكن هذا
هو المئات من المواطنين الأمريكيين عند
بوابة يافا أم أنا آسف عند
بوابة رافا اه إنهم عالقون إنهم
عالقون أيضًا ولا يمكنهم الخروج
منذ أسبوعين سألتك عن  لهم وقلت
حماس هي التي لن تسمح لهم بالخروج
أن الإسرائيليين كانوا مستعدين
المصريين كانوا مستعدين ماذا يحدث
متى يمكنهم
الخروج فكما أن هناك
مناقشات ومفاوضات جارية بشأن
الرهائن أه نحن نواجه
وضعا مماثلا  بالنسبة للمواطنين الأمريكيين
وغيرهم من الرعايا الأجانب المحاصرين
في غزة، صحيح أن المصريين
مستعدون للسماح للمواطنين الأمريكيين والمواطنين
الأجانب بالمرور عبر
بوابة رفح إلى مصر،
وليس لدى الإسرائيليين مشكلة في أن حماس
تمنع مغادرتهم وتجعلهم
سلسلة من المطالب لا أستطيع أن أتناول
هذه المطالب علناً ولكن هذا هو
موضوع المناقشات
والمفاوضات الجارية ونحن
نحاول العمل من خلال تلك المطالب للوصول إلى
نقطة نؤمن فيها
المرور الآمن لأي أمريكي  في غزة، من
يريد المغادرة، نحن على اتصال معهم بشكل
شبه يومي،
وسنواصل التركيز على هذا الأمر الذي يمثل
أولوية متساوية بالنسبة لنا لأن
إخراج الرهائن يتطلب منا أيضًا أن
نصل إلى نقطة حيث حماس
سيسمح لهم بالمرور الآمن، ونحن
نعمل جاهدين على تحقيق ذلك كل
يوم، وفي الوقت نفسه، أفاد حارث أن
مستوطنًا إسرائيليًا أطلق النار على
مدني فلسطيني في الضفة الغربية وقتله
بالأمس فقط، ويأتي ذلك بعد أن
حرص الرئيس بايدن على تحذير
نتنياهو من المستوطنين المتطرفين
في الضفة الغربية.  إن قول الضفة الغربية إن عليها أن توقف
هذه الهجمات المستمرة يشير لي إلى
أن نتنياهو لم يأخذ
تحذير الرئيس بايدن على محمل الجد على الرغم
من أن الرئيس بايدن رفع هذا
التحذير إلى مستوى تحذير عام، حيث
يُقتل الفلسطينيون حرفيًا في
الضفة الغربية على يد هؤلاء المستوطنين المتطرفين  الذي
وضع منشورات تحذر من
كنب آخر أه تم طرد الفلسطينيين حرفيا
من بلدة في الضفة الغربية
لعدم وجود من يحميهم
أه لماذا تعتقد أن نتنياهو
لم يأخذ التحذير على
محمل الجد
جيدا نعتقد أن رئيس الوزراء
يتحمل نتنياهو مسؤولية كبح جماح
المستوطنين المتطرفين في
الضفة الغربية الذين، كما قال الرئيس بايدن
قبل بضعة أيام، يصبون الزيت على
النار، ومن غير المقبول على الإطلاق أن
يكون هناك عنف من جانب المستوطنين المتطرفين ضد
الأبرياء في الضفة الغربية.
الشيء الذي سنواصل الضغط
عليه ليس حدثًا ليوم واحد، بل هو
تحدٍ مستمر وسيتطلب
جهدًا مستمرًا ومكثفًا من قبل الحكومة الإسرائيلية، وهذه
نقطة أعلنها الرئيس علنًا، إنها
نقطة سنوضحها باستمرار
بشكل خاص، ونتوقع مع مرور الوقت أن نرى
الحكومة الإسرائيلية تكثف جهودها في هذا الشأن،
وسأذهب إلى أبعد من ذلك لأن الرئيس
استخدم كلمة "المساءلة" بحيث
تكون هناك مساءلة لهؤلاء
المستوطنين المتطرفين الذين يشاركون في هذا النوع من
العنف.